across the broad expanse of history
there have been billions upon billions
of idiots as well as a handful of smart
people we interviewed some of the latter
group for our ongoing series great minds
people who think good
this week's people who thinks good
Stephen Hawking professor Stephen
Hawking is a pioneering physicist
international best-selling author and a
popular guest character on The Simpsons
if you are looking for trouble
you found it yeah just trying to use his
breakthrough work on black holes and
string theory is considered hugely
important by anyone who pretends to
understand it an expanding universe does
not preclude a creator I travel to the
Department of Applied Mathematics and
theoretical physics at Cambridge
University to speak with one of the
world's greatest living minds first off
congratulations on being the first
subject of our great mind series be
honest is this the single greatest honor
you have ever received yes good it's a
little hard to read your tone of voice
when you say that are you being
sarcastic yes I thought so um if there
is one thing you want people to
understand about your work bearing in
mind that most people will never
understand anything about your work what
would that thing be imaginary time
people think it's something you have in
dreams or when you're up against a
deadline but it's a well-defined concept
imaginary time is like another direction
in space it's the one bit of my work
science fiction writers have used
because they don't understand it idiots
people are such idiots because
presumably to my mind you're simply
talking about the theoretical
measurement obtained from real time by a
wink rotation of pi divided by two in
the complex
plain where T equals I times T she's not
that difficult to get your head around
um let's talk about artificial
intelligence in a recent op-ed column
you said and I quote success in creating
artificial intelligence would be the
biggest event in human history
unfortunately it might also be the last
are you saying that robots are going to
destroy humanity and is that a
scientific argument or the pitch for an
amazing movie artificial intelligence
could be a real danger in the
not-too-distant future it could design
improvements to itself and now it's
murder so I know you're trying to get
people to be cautious there but why
should I not be excited about fighting a
robot littles well ok for start we don't
know that do we we don't know that for
sure because what could a robot do that
I couldn't then fight back with by
simply just unplugging him right there's
a story that scientists built an
intelligent computer the first question
they asked it was is there a god the
computer replied there is now an a bolt
of lightning striking a plug so it
couldn't be turned off holy that's
the most terrifying story I've ever
heard
yes hold on who is talking to me right
now is it you or is the sentient
computer pretending to talk on your
behalf it's me yeah but how do I know
that professor because if computers had
become sentient what better way to
convince people they hadn't then by
co-opting the voice of the most
intelligent man on the planet you're a
idiot yep but who's saying that Steven
you or the machine both of us okay
alright we got that's actually quite
reassuring
okay um in 2006 you said in a world
that's in chaos politically socially and
environmentally how can the human race
sustain another hundred years a month
later you said I don't know the answer
that's why I asked the question to get
people to think about it and to be aware
of the dangers we now face so it's now
been a
is since then no pressure but have you
come up with an answer yet I still don't
have an answer at least a chance of
nuclear annihilation has diminished but
there are plenty of other dangers out
there okay see that's pretty depressing
professor because if I can explain this
to you you're the smartest man on earth
so if you can't come up with an answer
we are completely
moving on sure you're book smart Hawking
but are you street smart I'll give you a
hypothetical you're a mid-level drug
hustler okay you control around 12 city
blocks one of your suppliers Tito was
supposed to meet you behind the
warehouse at midnight to give you half a
kilo of medical-grade cocaine
Tito shows up late but he doesn't have
the drugs he says he was jumped but he
looks high what do you move Hawking I
don't don't your ex yep do you know what
that's actually the smartest possible
answer because all drug kingpins know
you don't do your own yes
well-played Hawking well-played um
you've stated that you believe there
could be an infinite number of parallel
universes does that mean that there is a
universe out there where I am smarter
than you yes and also a universe where
you're funny look if you're so smart
what number am I thinking of what it was
13 I was thinking of 13 um
okay that was a lucky guess what am I
thinking right now disappointment your
family I wasn't thinking that what would
I think that you know I'm trying as hard
as I can
why is that so hard for them to
understand hypothetically I wasn't
thinking that let's do some quick yes or
no questions are the following things
technically possible life on other
planets is that theoretically possible
yes okay uh what about a Schwarzschild
wormhole yes okay what about this uh me
going on a date with Charlize Theron
yeah
not at all in in no universe or in in
none of the infinite universes does that
happen it's completely beyond the bounds
of scientific possibilities what you're
saying yes a quick follow-up question in
any of those potential universes and
either one rejecting her and that's why
it doesn't work out no you to realize
that typing your response is difficult
for me correct
okay sure yeah it's just I'm trying to
play this out because it just I just
trying to see if there was any
hypothetical hole it doesn't matter but
but never say never okay if time travel
were possible would you want to go back
in time and refuse to do this interview
yes you truly are an incredibly smart
man Stephen Hawking thank you so much
for your time